إنها صفقة تزوير هنا لدينا
دولة مزورة لدينا دولة فاسدة
لدينا دولة ليس لها حدود لدينا
دولة ليس لديها سوى
المشاكل
[تصفيق]
يهددونني بالسجن لمدة 400 عام
لحيازتي أوراقي الرئاسية الخاصة  إن ما
فعله كل رئيس آخر تقريبًا هو أحد أكثر
النظريات القانونية شناعة وشراسة التي تم
طرحها على الإطلاق في محكمة قانونية أمريكية،
شكرًا لك،
إنهم يدمرون بلدنا،
وعندما أعيد انتخابي وسنعيد
انتخابنا، ليس لدينا أي شيء  خيار لن يكون لدينا
دولة بعد الآن،
سأمحو الدولة العميقة تمامًا، وسنمحوها ونحن نعرف من
هم، أعرف بالضبط من هم
[موسيقى]
النقطة التي يجب أن يلاحقها مدع عام خاص حقيقي
الرئيس الفاسد في
تاريخ الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية جو بايدن
وعائلة بايدن الإجرامية بأكملها
يسمون مدعيًا خاصًا
وجميع الآخرين المتورطين في
تدمير انتخاباتنا
وحدودنا وبلدنا نفسه